guten tag nach peking die drohungen der
chinesischen führung die waren ja im
vorfeld wirklich massiv wie ernst muss
man das jetzt nehmen
ich glaube man muss diese drogen ernst
nehmen weil der chinesische präsident
jean ping sie sehr ernst meint man muss
wissen dass die ping der ansicht ist
dass taiwan eine abtrünnige insel ist
und eben zurück zu china gehört zurück
ins reich der mitte dass es seine
historisch mission das will erreichen
dass hat er auch immer wieder gesagt
notfalls auch mit gewalt und da kommt
der besuch einer hochrangigen us
politikerin für ihn nicht gut sieht
darin eigentlich den versuch amerikas
die eigenständigkeit taiwans zu
unterstreichen und das werde auf alle
fälle verhindern was kann passieren wohl
sehr schlimm im fall wäre dass es
angedroht worden dass wenn sie dann nach
thailand fliegt das sie chinesische
kampfflugzeuge quasi begleiten und auf
sichtweise sind das wäre doch dann fast
schon eine physische eskalation
vielleicht kommt es nicht so weit
vielleicht wird es einfach mehr militär
manöver jetzt geben aber egal was
passiert eins ist klar das verhältnis
zwischen den beiden weltmächten amerika
und china wird durch diesen besuch
wesentlich belastet und stärker belastet
und das ist kein guter tag für den
weltfrieden weil man ja doch hofft
vielleicht auf westlicher seite dass
china sich stärker engagieren würde um
auch auf russland einzuwirken im ukraine
krieg das kann man wahrscheinlich mit
diesem besuch vergessen insofern ist das
heute wie gesagt das duell der welt
möchte dass sie stark dass ich weiter
verschafft ulf röller live aus peking
vielen dank bis hierher und wir bekommen
gleich von ihnen jetzt noch mal einen
tieferen einblick und eine politische
bilanz zum wirken des chinesischen
staatspräsidenten she denn er gibt ja
die leitlinie vor führt das land mit
harter hand und hat china in den letzten
jahren auch deutlich verändert mehr
unterdrückung mehr nationalismus und
mehr aufrüstung
er malt die die chinas schicksal
bestimmten und bestimmen bilder für die
geschichtsbücher john cummins pinsel
sucht die größe in den personen der
steuermann überragt alle die ihm folgten
nun wandelt ein anderer auf seinen
spuren gibt will auch ein ewiger
präsident werden jaja binz kunst darf
daher nur verehrung und keinen zweifel
kennen
präsident sie hat ein rundes gesicht
dass es gar nicht so einfach zumal ich
will ihn als einen menschen darstellen
der dem volk sehr nahe steht
seine kunden sind loyale
parteimitglieder und reiche unternehmer
viele wollen einen sie zu hause hängen
haben verehrung schützt denn sie trägt
nicht nur den mao anzug bei der 100 jahr
feier der partei er will wie mario die
absolute macht mit einem volk das dient
was wird präsident skis vermächtnis sein
ich bin nicht in der position darüber zu
urteilen
er lässt sich onkel schienen inszeniert
sich als volkstribun gerade auch bei
seinem besuch in china
die uiguren die unterdrückte muslimische
minderheit müssen tanzen sie bestimmt
wird zur china dazu gehört wer einen
anderen gott neben ihn hat der landet im
lager
es ist nicht übertrieben von einem
rechtspopulistisch nationalismus zu
sprechen dies entspricht dem trend den
wir in der welt beobachten konnten zb
bei putin und erdogan
sieht sich als anführer der
kommunistischen welt beim bündnis mit
putin geht es um die neue weltordnung
archivbild die demokratische insel
taiwan mit dem festland china verein
notfalls mit militärischer gewalt ein
duell der weltmächte amerika china droht
die chinesische führung ist entschlossen
zu zeigen dass china besser aufgestellt
ist als liberaler demokratien dass man
effizient war innovation eure
technologien hervorbringen kann dass man
gesellschaften besser prägen kann um
auch mit krisen und so geht
die ersten zwei jahre corona kampf waren
für sie ein triumph wie ein siegreicher
feldherr besuchte er wohin doch dann
legte seine 0 kowitz strategie erst
shanghai lahm und dann chinas wirtschaft
seitdem leidet das land aber keiner wagt
zu widersprechen
sie hat sich die partei unterworfen
seine gegner ins gefängnis gesteckt wie
einst mal herrscht er mit absoluter
macht
der unterschied glaube ich ist auch zu
beginn seiner amtszeit dass die leute
sich jetzt oftmals bekennen müssen das
heißt nicht mehr oder es reicht nicht
mehr einfach nur zu schweigen sich
wegzuducken
hat die volksrepublik gegründet wie will
sie jetzt zu nie dagewesener größe
führen ein chinesisches jahrhundert das
ist die historische mission